[Musique]
et c'est l'une des actualités média du
jour effet c'est ce qui fait le plus
polémique en ce moment c'est la sortie
du livre sur jean luc delarue par
vincent mêlée c'est un ancien patron de
france est évident au saint patron de
l'os 3 ans devait d'offrir de france 3
il a fait la branche 3 et ensuite france
2 c'est le livre s'appelle jean luc
delarue la star qui ne s'aimait pas et
dans ce livre pouvoir beaucoup
d'extraits particulièrement trash on
aura ensuite le témoignage en
exclusivité je voulais dit de la maman
de jean luc delarue
mais vous allez voir c'est très très
touchant c'est un document exclusif en
attendant on vous a fait un résumé
regardez ça moi je suis comme un final
sur jean luc lory en plus vous avez fait
votre première télé avec lui mais c'est
vrai qu'il m'a fait commencé à la
télévision c'est ben ouais voilà jean
luc yves ouellet gelé après bien plus
tard avait été favorable à ma
candidature
oui mais voilà donc on emballait en tout
cas le livre il fait couler ainsi jean
luc delarue était l'animateur phare de
france télévisions il nous a tristement
quitté il ya maintenant six ans suite à
un cancer
sa vie a été marquée par d'immenses
succès professionnel mais aussi ternie
par des problèmes d'addiction six ans
après un livre événement va être publiée
sur sa vie et nous promet des
révélations chocs sur sa face cachée des
révélations notamment sur ses addictions
de la rue et trouver dans les pires
endroits mise à mal au milieu de
clochards attaché à un radiateur dans
une chambre d'hôtel parfois il faut
juste le forcer à bouger lorsqu il
s'enferme dans son appartement fenêtres
fermées des jours et des jours lorsque
de la au sort du studio commence la
lente et pénible redescente les caméras
ne sont plus là pour le protéger
l'alcool et le shit et plus tard la
cocaïne
ne sont plus des gens qui donnent mais
également une terrible révélation sur un
sombre soir où jean luc delarue avait
décidé d'en finir avec la vie
jean-luc passe par les voies sur berge
non loin du pont où la princesse diana
trouvera la mort en 97 il pousse la
musique à fond puis se tourne vers elle
ça on saura mieux là haut tout sans nom
il accélère tout le monde crie dans
l'habitacle la voiture finit par se
fracasser contre un trop tôt de la
bretelle de sortie avant de faire trois
tonneaux
alors une question se pose maintenant
six ans après sa mort sa mémoire et elle
trahi fallait-il publier ce livre sur
jean luc delarue falletti publier ce
livre sur jean luc delarue alors comme
vous l'a montré dans la vidéo certains
passages du livre sont juste hallucinant
notamment quand il parle des soirées et
des fontes de jean luc delarue on veut
en parler tout de suite nicolas
pernikoff nous a rejoint nicolas cage
très heureux parce que c'est un ami en
plus plutôt là rien énormément et
nicolas vous étiez donc numéro 3 de
france télévisions ont déjà ici si
facile parce que je me dis non il faut
arrêter voilà faut le dire et vous aviez
d'ailleurs proposer un truc à jean luc
delarue
juste avant qu'ils s'en aillent et vous
faisiez qu'il fasse le disant moi
j'étais pas le meilleur ami de jean luc
delarue j'ai connu jean luc delarue sur
plutôt vers la fin exactement vrai
france télévisions en 2000 2010 2011 et
j'avais ce projet est effectivement de
faire avec lui un prêt access cessa 19
heures exactement à 12h à 18h et jean
luc delarue sûr que ça aurait cartonné
alors il parle de ce type dans ce titre
des soirées de défense alors ceux qui
pensent qu'il fallait publier livres 10
sont à droite ceux qui pensent que non
sont ici alors de la rue et trouver dans
les pires endroits mise à mal au milieu
de clochards attaché à un radiateur dans
une chambre d'hôtel et parfois je n'ai
au ps on fait parfois la fio pas s'il
vous plaît nabila parfois il faut juste
forcé à bouger lorsqu il s'enferme dans
son appartement fenêtres fermées des
jours et des jours
est ce que vous êtes choqués donc ceux
qui disent qu'il fallait pas publier le
livre vous nabila vous dit non mais en
fait
merci nabias si vous n'êtes jamais me
oui parce que cela va tellement
dégueulasse de salaire qui est berciaud
je trouve ça scandaleux
voilà ça me fait vraiment mal au coeur
pourquoi parce qu'il n'est plus là pour
répondre parce que c'est quelqu'un qui a
révolutionné la télé de ce mario c'est
quelqu'un qui aime les gens on le voyait
à l'antenne je trouve que ça fait mal
justement de voir des années après qu'il
ne soit plus là de concentré de mettre
un coup de projecteur sur
qui n'allait pas qui n'a pas de faille
tout le monde a des forces et des
failles pourquoi mettre un coup de
projecteur des yeux sur ses failles
après il y allait révolutionner
tellement de choses dans la télévision
que ça n aurait pu au moins saluer sa
mémoire proprement
alors il ya aussi un livre lorsque de la
rue sort du studio commence la lente et
pénible redescendre les caméras ne sont
plus là pour le protéger
l'alcool et le shit et plus tard la
cocaïne ne sont plus des antidotes est
la chose la plus dure est à propos des
envies suicidaires vous allez voir je
vous montrais dans un instant ce qu'ils
ont dit parce qu'il est dit dans ce ive
sur ses envies suicidaires c'est
complètement fou et dans un instant on
verra on aura le le document sur sur sa
maman qui nous a laissés un document
audio gilles je suis pas du tout
d'accord
moi j'ai lu le livre oui à des passages
qui sont très dur mais c'est le récit
d'une autodestruction très très bien
fait on le dit et la liberté de l'accord
pour que pour construire sa vie sert
ménez en a le droit
on a le droit en france d'écrire sur des
gens qui aiment les cdc du tout c'est un
livre qui est extrêmement documenté il
est passionnant de bout en bout
[Musique]
nicolas carole parce que carole chaix et
morel une livre donc je peux pas me
prononcer maintenant
pourtant ils sont nés en 2000 il s'en
expliquer lui-même de ses addictions etc
où il était encore là donc c'était quand
même de notoriété publique et après je
pense que c'était quand même quelqu'un
qui était pas bien dans sa peau du tout
donc à temps et avec laquelle la
question il faut penser aux
téléspectateurs c'est ce qui est plus
important
jean luc delarue est un génie de la
télévision ça c'est le jeu rappelle
qu'il a fait c'est mon choix qui était
aussi celle des révolutions votre
histoire à la grande famille 16 discute
qui était en fait le rct l'eau fera
winfrey française il a été un génie de
la télévision pourquoi aujourd'hui est
ce qu'on a besoin de faire partager aux
téléspectateurs qui ont rêvé sur jean
luc delarue jean luc delarue s'était
c'était le le fils le fils de deux
millions de gens est telle aujourd'hui
cette fois est ce qu'on a besoin de
rêver genre de choses et de l'ess avait
personnellement alors le lieu dans le
livre je sais plus qui vient d'en parler
j'ai lu ce livre assez rapidement tout à
l'heure c'est vrai qu'il est bien écrit
oui alors alors roulage habib essid
vincent rey parce qu'il est extrêmement
bien écrit maintenant il ya deux choses
est-ce qu'on n'a pas un devoir de
réserve quand on travaille la télévision
et qu'on a occupé nos positions sur les
animateurs parce que moi je pourrais
écrire des encyclopédies a écrit vers
tous les animateurs
notre rôle c'est de faire rêver les
téléspectateurs c'est pas d'aller
raconter que des gens parce que les gens
se sont alors s'il vous plaît attendez
je vais vous dire un autre passage parce
que c'est un espace âges les plus durs
jean-luc passe par les voir s'ils
passent par les voies sur berge non loin
du pont où la princesse diana trouvera
la mort en 1997 il pousse la musique à
fond puis se tourner vers elsa on sera
mieux là haut tous ensemble non il
accélère tout le monde crie tout le
monde crie dans l'habitacle la voiture
finit par se fracasse alors contre un
poteau de la bretelle de sortie
trois tonneaux c'est une histoire
complètement folle lac et danse libre
parce qu'on on apprend quand même des
choses moi je savais pas du tout ce dont
on avait fait avoir c'est incroyable si
j'appelle mon niveau lui nicolas moi
c'était vraiment quelqu'un que j'aimais
profondément et un ami une personne n'a
jamais été aussi durs sur lui-même que
lui dans le livre qu'il a écrit et moi
j'allais chine juste qu'il me racontait
des passages de ce livre c'est bien pire
que ce cas là dedans moi ce livre
j'étais farouchement contre et quand je
lui je me suis dit c'est un travail
honnête de quelqu'un qui veut faire le
symbole d'une période faire de l'argent
il revient non non papa vincent la star
qui ne s'aimait pas c'est tellement sa
bien aimée paris mais personne n'a
jamais autant salies jean luc delarue
que les médias de son vivant elle c'est
de ça dont il a le dessouchage assez
d'accord avec israël c'est vrai qu'il
sait les médias qui ont le plus sali
jean luc delarue de son vivant ça je
suis assez d'accord élus et c'est vrai
que l'on a tellement souffert que je
pense que voilà il est payant ou alors
on aura bien moins de sa mère nora le
témoignage de sa mère dijana ce document
ses documentaires qui est passé à 10,8 à
l'époque ce que ses limites et on
s'était ce genre sont les c'était déjà
un peu sur les façons de jean luc
delarue notamment sur le rapport entre
les employés jean-luc visiblement celui
ci faisait un peu peur aux employés de
sa boîte c'est ce qui se disait regarde
jean luc dans les couloirs de sa boîte
de production est loin d'être un homme
affable
montre inflexible et redoutable avec ses
collaborateurs très dur très cassantes
exigeront pas toujours très délicat dans
sa façon d'exprimer les critiques
moi j'ai vu des gens sautent aux
licenciés mais puisque c'est ça je m'en
vais je m'auto les sensibles s'est donné
lieu à des scènes et perd théâtrale dans
les couloirs pendant longtemps les gens
me demandaient aussi site il vrai jean
luc et moi je me demandais qui c'est
vrai jean luc est ce que c'est le mec
absolument parfait ou est ce que c'est
le mec qui peut être absolument odieux
avec ses collaborateurs qui en fait je
me suis rendu compte que c'était des
deux c'est flou il s'agit avait vu ça ça
avait fait un énorme carton d'ailleurs
un succès vite et je lis dans un instant
on aura vraiment un document exclusif
c'est un simple sa maman nous
enregistrer voilà exceptionnel depuis la
mort de son c'est incroyable moi je suis
là et je l'avais vu dans le reportage
puisqu'un autre extrait on voit maryse
donc sa maman expliqué dans le
documentaire le moment où il a compris
que jean-luc perdre est complètement les
pédales
on a regardé et après je vous passerais
l'extrait qu'elle nous a faits pour
aujourd'hui vraiment pour eux ce qu'elle
pense du livre et je vraiment jeune moi
j'ai il avait montré de trois fois la
télé j'adore sa maman vraiment c'est
elle et elle est allée elle est
formidable regardez jean luc veut
montrer son succès les étrangement il
restera caché durant ces soirées
mais cette démonstration de puissance va
voir l'effet opposé sur sa maman elle
aussi invitée à ces fêtes
largement sa lenteur parce qu'on est
dans la démesure je le sens je ressens
je me méfie toi je voulais tout va dans
le mur aujourd'hui tu es ce que tu
imagines jour d'arrêter
jean-luc à quoi ça sert de gagner tout
ce pognon jean lui prends soin de toi je
vais te fatigue - j'en ai que j'ai envie
de changer et les vallées jusqu'à la
rupture mais c'est vrai que ça c'est fou
je trouve que le témoignage et de saint
amand est tellement vrai là dessus je
trouve vraiment elle parle voilà elle
parle comme une maman et et c'est ça qui
font aujourd'hui une petite anecdote
j'ai passé dans le livre mais souvent
dans ces soirées où n'allait pas il
était de retrancher dans une sorte de
rija côté et regarder les écrans
télévision et le zoom et regarder les
personnes qui étaient là comme quelqu'un
qui était dans dans un autre monde
qu'avait s'isoler dans deux cas
réveillés depuis de tout le monde
c'était vraiment quelqu'un qui avait
lantiss de la foule des autres et des
lui-même gens me le jeu monsieur gilles
c'est quand même hallucinant
nicolas que vous ériger en comité de
censure de la télévision française on
dirait ma blonde qui vous aident comme
ça aujourd'hui ce que la loi d'améliorer
sa pelle la liberté ne viendrait à
l'esprit et on n'a pas besoin
jours oui c'est vrai nicolas s'il vous
plaît nicolas a laissé nicolas dans
répondez lui parce que là c'est énorme
et c'est incroyable ce qui vient de cgg
aucun souci avec ça juste un truc est ce
que le téléspectateur est arrivée de
jean luc delarue qui était un homme qui
a amené énormément de choses la
télévision a besoin de connaître tous
les travers de l'homme j'ai des amis là
vous êtes formidables et vous avez une
talons maintenant ça ne me regarde pas
votre vie privée ne regarde pas et j'en
ai entendu parler ne regarde personne
alors s'il vous plaît il a bel bien et
aucun moyen des 100 est un témoignage
d'un des employés de de réservoir prod
donc sonda société de production qui
parlait du rapport de jean luc avec la
drôle voilà avec la drogue et c'est vrai
qu' apparemment c'est un secret de
polichinelle tout le monde savait voilà
et d'ailleurs même il a dit alors je
vais vous dire un truc que cette fois
ses amis proches ou des gens qui ont
travaillé avec lui dans sa boîte très
peu se sont exprimés dans le livre rien
fait c'est vrai pourquoi pas si on le
respectait tout simplement
même s'il était bien ici on vous a
demandé de tout c'est un patron
difficile
il était respecté sur mon frère a su ce
qui l'a amené à abidjan demain cyril si
on fait un livre sur vous à quoi
s'attend pas si jean luc delarue a dit
tout ce qu'il avait à dire de son vivant
et compris les phases les plus sombres
de sa vie pas besoin qu'un qu'une tierce
personne vienne les redit le champ
ailleurs c'est l'art ailleurs raison
c'était là un enfant qui n'est pas
encore un jeune algérois l'adolescent il
faut il penser aussi à glace alors
un frère il ya une maman qui viendra
ensuite le témoignage de sa réponse atta
mills escale en poche regarder d'abord
l'extrait il est de plus en plus nerveux
et difficile à suivre dans ses
raisonnements même s'il n'a jamais
consommé de drogue à la vue de tous à
réservoir prod
tout le monde a deviné que jean luc est
un consommateur on en a jamais parlé
non à 2 me mo tiens jean luc rigaut fait
un truc un peu c'est quoi ces de la
cendre banon s'était fume plus depuis
cinq ans qu'est ce qu'ils voulaient là
que je faisais alors c'est quoi où on en
parle
ne parlez pas
non mais si moi j'étais fan de jean luc
delarue absolue 2 est-ce que avant
d'écouter le témoignage c'est rarement
est ce que vous trouvez qu'ils ont
aujourd'hui franchement en télé d'aussi
grosses tares que jean luc delarue
nabila savall téléphone et qu'est ce qui
t'arrive chez rim dit qu'elle me laisse
parler les jours d'accord mais tu te
couches jetables non mais c'est vrai ce
qui est franchement d'aussi grosses
cartes que jean luc delarue singstar
série la relance aujourd'hui il n'y a
pas d'équivalent
jean luc delarue mais puisque c'est une
époque est beaucoup moins de chaînes et
sur les chaînes très puissants comme tf1
on de ouf once de on était tout de suite
des stars énorme c'est comme il y avait
comme il y avait comme vous un truc
rares comme vous alors pardonnez moi par
rapport au monde du handicap c'était le
seul qui savait parler aussi bien un
patron tout cas un jeune garçon et ce
cas quelqu'un qui avait le syndrome de
gilles de la ville
jamais jamais rencontré un animateur
possible un humain est aussi vrai que
par rapport à toutes les diversités et
ben oui il a inventé une télé qui est
arrivé après factual qui est de raconter
une histoire c'est à dire qu'à l'epoque
jour après jour où ça se discute était
prônons si vous n'aviez pas l'inviter
vous regardez quand même le sujet parce
qu'il arrivait à vous prendre
complètement mais c'est justement pour
ça
sa boîte de prod lui a survécu c'est
rarissime madrid était endetté animateur
producteur c'est m
le seul club cela et moi j'ai appelé cet
après midi quelques copains qui bosse à
savoir et l'esprit dont luc et est dans
la boîte et franchement et c'est très
fort d'avoir déjà vendu il a vendu sa
boîte mort avec les quatre ou cinq
dirigeants et les employés qui ont
racheté une balle hors les cherry on a
contacté la maman de jean luc delarue
maryse que j'aime vraiment énormément
voyage qu'il dit et on a en exclusivité
son témoignage elle a accepté de se
livrer à des pmp
c'est très très bouleversant regarde
comme d'habitude l'invasion de l'asie
prises et agressé la fragilité d'un
homme profondément et l'intérêt qu'elle
acquérait complètement contraire comme
en suisse nous a donné parle d'un homme
qui était sur quoi que ce soit
les cinq dernières années de sa vie
voilà six étages région luc si tous les
sites à jean-luc abîmée par la notoriété
à l'argent par la vitesse un truc je
trouve que verra-t-on s'élance voilà
c'est moi je trouve que la réponse de sa
maman encore lady et je vais vous dire
la vérité
pour moi c'est pas ce que vont dire les
téléspectateurs mais la réponse de saint
avold pour moi c'est un fake c'est ça sa
maman qu'il fallait demander sa maman
est choqué si sa maman et choqué de ce
livre c'est qu'il fallait pas le publier
je suis désolé abbassi bah moi je suis
non mais s'ils devaient savoir la
réponse avril téléspectateurs non merci
rien de pire que salir la mémoire de
quelqu'un est décédé vers sigean le
v-twin eux jean-luc delarue fallait-il
publier ce livre
oui à 31% non à 69 % ils suivent voilà
la vie de la maman de jean luc delarue
et je comprends voilà il faudra si sa
maman est choqué l encan là vous croyez
que ça lui fait du bien ça vraiment en
tant que ça sur son fils et de voir
encore des débats sur ce qui s'est passé
alors qu'elle a perdu green c'est
l'objectif du livre
voilà le vinson délai est plutôt une
bonne personne alors vincent revient à
france télévisions et à la télévision
qui a beaucoup beaucoup aimé jean luc
delarue oui qui était même peut-être
fans des sommes à la rue donc c'est pas
du tout une méchante personnes non non
quel est l'objectif des livres il a
rappelé sa maman avant merci c'est
cheryl cole débat là dessus